Transcriptor: laura monforte
Revisor: Juan Ignacio Barcos Spezzi
Me voy a permitir,
por ser el que cierra las intervenciones,
todas extraordinarias y estimulantes,
el decir que, en efecto, hemos podido
comprobar que se han cumplido objetivos
como el de la interdisciplinariedad.
Cantidad de disciplinas procedentes de
profesiones distintas han coincidido aquí.
Han coincidido hombres y mujeres
inteligentes, hablando muy bien,
pero que sería decir
que también es muy interesante
que nos hemos reunido jóvenes y mayores.
Eso es importantísimo.
Es decir, el diálogo,
la colaboración intergeneracional,
es otro de los desafíos que tiene
en este momento la sociedad, ¿no?
Porque tenemos aún
la idea de que las edades
son unos pasos por unos tramos.
Son formas de habitar
territorios distintos.
La edad son territorios.
Por tanto, el poder colaborar
entre esos territorios
es otra de las cosas que
en estos momentos tenemos como desafío.
Así que quería aprovechar,
ya que soy el de más edad
y que, curiosamente,
voy a hablar de futuro.
(Risas)
Presentadora: Un aplauso.
A.R.: Muchas gracias.
-Gracias
(Aplausos)
Y gracias porque para mí
es un placer y un estímulo
el que me escuchéis durante unos minutos
que os voy a hablar de las utopías.
Y hablar hoy de las utopías, pero
las utopías no son ensoñaciones.
¿No decimos cuando alguien
nos presenta una cosa:
"Sí, sí, es muy interesante"?
Pero decimos: "Pero es utópico".
Una forma suave de decir
que es irrealizable.
¿Y no guardamos también en nosotros
esa sospecha de que la utopía es engaño?
¿Y si fuera todo lo contrario?
¿Si la utopía, hoy, fuera una necesidad?
Una necesidad para salir del presente.
Una necesidad para revelarse
contra aquellos que nos dicen
que el presente es suficiente,
que los valores, los modelos,
el sistema son incuestionables,
que, en todo caso, eso sí,
se pueden... retocar,
para mejorarlos, para amplificarlos.
Pero donde estén las certezas
que nos preservan con ese cobijo
de la intemperie, de la incertidumbre,
que por favor no lo removamos.
Y es que las utopías
se llevan mal con el poder.
¿Por qué? Porque las utopías arrancan
de una disconformidad con el presente,
una crítica, un análisis
crítico del presente.
Pero para que esa disconformidad
no se convierta en frustación,
la utopía aporta, además, imaginación,
creación de escenarios posibles.
Posibles. Y sí, ¿por qué no?
Escenarios posibles que permitan decir:
"Oye, estamos aquí,
en esta ventanilla del tren,
y me estás diciendo que hemos llegado
a la estación terminal.
¡Pero si esto es un apeadero!
¿Por qué te empeñas en decirnos
que ya hemos llegado?".
Esa rebeldía es la clave de la utopía.
Pero hay que añadir otra cosa,
también muy importante:
la utopía es seducción.
Tiene que ser seductora.
¿Por qué? Porque hay que remover
el valle de la cotidianeidad.
Pero para entrar en el papel
que tienen las utopías en el presente,
quiero que nos fijemos
en algo que, aunque es habitual,
a lo mejor no le prestamos
especial atención.
Cierto que todos aceptamos
que nos situamos en el espacio,
pero también nos situamos en el tiempo,
como quiero haceros ver.
Nos situamos en el espacio y decimos:
"Allí. Por allí sale el sol.
Por ahí se pone".
Pero también, en el tiempo, decimos:
"Ahí, está el pasado,
ahí está el futuro
y aquí, aquí está mi lugar
en el tiempo: el presente".
Pero lo curioso
es que durante prácticamente
toda nuestra existencia como humanos,
en esta línea del tiempo,
nos hemos colocado así.
Fijaos: así, mirando el pasado.
Porque en el pasado estaba todo dicho.
Ahí estaban los héroes y sus hazañas
que teníamos que imitar.
Ahí estaban las divinidades
con sus revelaciones.
Ahí estaban los monarcas bienhechores,
y ahí también,
los sabios con sus inventos.
Todo eso lo teníamos que recoger
e intentar, en lo posible,
replicarlo, instalarlo, en eso,
en nuestro lugar en el tiempo:
en el presente.
Y como naturalmente somos imperfectos,
nunca conseguíamos hacer una copia,
una reproducción exacta
de ese áureo e imitable pasado.
Así que generaba permanentemente
esa sensación que
ha arrastrado el ser humano
de culpabilidad por no estar a la altura.
Bien. El pasado, aquí el presente
y ¿dónde está el futuro?
A nuestra espalda.
Es decir, no lo vemos en esta posición.
Y ya sabemos que todo aquello
que no vemos, nos produce temor,
que todo lo malo llega sin verlo.
Así que para esta posición, prácticamente
durante toda nuestra existencia,
el futuro era el fin de los tiempos.
El futuro era porvenir, pero cuando venía,
se acababa el tiempo, se acababa
el concepto que teníamos de ese tiempo.
Así que ¿os dais de cuenta
de la cantidad de culturas
que han interpretado esta forma
de situarnos en el tiempo
y, por tanto, del futuro como por venir
con el fin de los tiempos?
Una catástrofe, en muchos casos,
purificadora de este género humano,
el futuro como advenimiento.
Pues bien, muy recientemente,
hemos empezado a hacer
un trascendental...
–bueno, "recientemente"... unos 500 años,
que no es nada para la vida humana–
y hemos empezado
a hacer un giro trascendental
que ha sido este
que estoy haciendo yo ahora.
Es decir, ir dejando atrás el pasado.
El pasado queda atrás,
y enfrentarte ¿con qué?
Con la niebla del futuro.
Así que frente a ese esplendoroso
pasado que había que imitar,
ahora, los humanos nos encontramos
con un futuro neblinoso.
Tan neblinoso, que es la niebla
más densa e inquietante
que tiene el ser humano,
que ¿cuál es?
La niebla de la incertidumbre.
Es tal el efecto que nos produce,
que ahora todos los humanos
tenemos tortícolis.
No podemos dejar de
mirar atrás ¡ay! ese pasado,
ese pasado añorado,
porque esto es impresionante.
Por eso, cuando
nos encontramos con esa niebla,
aparecen las clásicas utopías
que todos conocemos:
la de Tomás Moro, la de Francis Bacon,
la de Tommaso Campanella,
que ¿qué nos decían todas ellas?
Nos decían: "Detrás de la niebla
está el futuro".
El futuro es un lugar, por eso
todas las utopías clásicas...
Las utopías son una ciudad
esplendorosa, una isla.
Y ¿os dais cuenta de que
toda la estructura narrativa
consiste en que alguien
ha llegado allí, la ha descubierto
y vuelve a contárnoslo,
para emocionarnos
y aceptar el riesgo del extravío,
atravesar la niebla y alcanzar el futuro?
Pues eso ha llegado. Esa forma
de entender el futuro ha llegado
hasta finales del XIX.
El concepto de progreso
tan decimonónico es esa idea.
El futuro está.
Lo que hay que hacer
es progresar para alcanzarlo.
Pero en el XXI no.
Ahora todos nosotros no vemos esto así.
Cierto, estamos ante la niebla del futuro.
Pero detrás de la niebla, detrás
de la niebla, no hay más que niebla.
Así que no hay que atravesarla
como esos navegantes de la época,
que era la que inspiraba estas utopías,
que descubrían territorios.
No, no hay que atravesarla:
hay que desplazarla.
Y se desplaza construyendo.
Así que nos estamos encontrando
los contemporáneos,
ya no el futuro como por venir,
ya no el futuro por llegar,
por alcanzarlo,
sino el futuro por hacer.
Y claro, nos produce una zozobra
pensar que el futuro
está en nuestras manos.
Y si esta forma de ver el tiempo
nos generaba culpabilidad,
esta forma de ver el tiempo
nos genera una sensación inmensa
de responsabilidad.
Por eso, ahora, nos gusta
más a los contemporáneos
que nos metan miedo,
y eso se llama "distopía".
Nos gusta escuchar las distopías,
como les gusta a los niños
que les cuenten historias de miedo
cuando se van a dormir.
Eso sí, te la escuchan
con la sábana tapándola.
Pues eso hacemos los humanos,
nos gustan las series de "Black Mirror".
¿Por qué? Porque nos están, con ese miedo,
confirmando nuestros temores.
Pero ¿qué diferencia hay
entre utopía y distopía?
Cierto, las dos son críticas
con el presente.
Están disconformes con el presente.
Pero fijaros qué estrategia más distinta
de crear el escenario motivador.
La distopía te presenta
un escenario vertiginoso,
es decir, te aproxima a un precipicio.
Y te dice: "Si seguimos
como estamos en el presente,
ahí tienes el vértigo del precipicio".
Eso está bien, pero produce
algo preocupante.
Y es que ese vértigo te puede producir
temor y encogimiento.
En cambio, la utopía te dice:
"¿Te das cuenta de que, si conseguimos
saber salir del presente,
nos encontramos con la emergencia de
un potencial que llevamos los humanos?".
Ese es el escenario posible
que podemos alcanzar.
¿Veis la diferencia tan importante?
Y apuesto por eso.
¿Por qué apuesto por eso?
Porque llevamos 3500 millones de años
demostrando que la estrategia
principal de la evolución
–somos nosotros también evolución–
ha consistido en poder soportar
el efecto destructor de la incertidumbre
con la diversidad.
Generar muchas formas y funciones
distintas para que ese azar incontrolable
siempre tenga una respuesta
por parte de la vida
con una forma adecuada.
Ha funcionado tan bien
que aquí estamos nosotros,
que somos producto de la evolución.
Pero le devolvemos a esta evolución
que nos ha colocado en el universo,
le devolvemos el favor,
y se lo devolvemos extraordinariamente.
¿Por qué? Porque este cerebro
aporta una estrategia
nueva extraordinaria.
Ya no solo la de la diversidad,
sino la capacidad de prever.
De prever, de imaginar un futuro.
No esperar que la incertidumbre llegue,
sino intentar prever
y construir un futuro.
Eso es impresionante, y lo venimos
haciendo, como humanos,
desde el primer momento que tomamos
un canto rodado, formas redondas,
y, como preveíamos, como imaginábamos,
nuestra mano era conducida
por la imagen que queríamos alcanzar
y golpeábamos así consecuentemente
la piedra, y salía el bifaz.
Y salía el hacha de piedra.
Pues desde ese primer golpe hasta
este mundo que hemos construido
lo hemos hecho porque lo hemos imaginado.
Así que, por favor,
¿cómo en este momento
de encrucijada no reaccionamos?
¿Cómo no apostamos por la imaginación,
la disconformidad crítica
y la capacidad de hacer ver a los otros
lo que podemos construir nosotros
con nuestras propias manos?
Y solamente deciros: por favor,
por favor, educación.
Liberad las hormas que impiden
que este impulso natural
de crear que tiene el cerebro,
se ahoguen con las normas
que ahora todos criticamos.
Muchísimas gracias. Muy amables.
(Aplausos)
Gracias, muchas gracias,
muy amables.
(Aplausos)
¡A construir todos utopías!
¡Y, sobre todo, enseñársela a los jóvenes!